después de más de un mes de reapertura
varios países de américa latina
continúan acumulando contagios se
acercan al millón de casos de kobe 19 el
sábado colombia el quinto país del mundo
más golpeado por el virus superó los 800
mil positivos un día después de sumar
más de 25 mil decesos ahora se encuentra
en una cuarentena selectiva más flexible
con la reapertura de restaurantes
negocios vuelos nacionales y algunos
internacionales que bueno para la
economía que esto ya está oportunidad
para que la gente pueda tener sus
negocios funcionando porque esa parte es
importante pero de todas maneras no
quiere decir que estamos ya fuera de
pandemia estamos en un riesgo de
producto otro pico de pandemia y tenemos
que tomar una actitud responsable
definitivamente pero también superó la
barrera de los 800 mil contagios el país
andino acumula más de 32.000 fallecidos
pese a que el número de
hospitalizaciones está disminuyendo el
gobierno peruano anunció la prórroga del
estado de emergencia hasta el 31 de
octubre sin embargo a comienzos de ese
mismo mes el país dará un paso más en su
reactivación económica
las fronteras aéreas con algunas
naciones vecinas eso de pretender pasar
a la fase 4 de actividades económicas de
abrir gimnasios bares discotecas
y otras formas de entretenimiento
sería terrible y si podría llevarnos más
rápidamente a una segunda ola méxico con
más de 725 mil contagios es el segundo
país de la región con mayor tasa de
muertos por detrás de brasil epicentro
de la enfermedad en américa latina' que
roza los 5 millones de contagios y
argentinas con una de las cuarentenas
más largas del mundo también supera los
700 mil casos confirmados pese a las
advertencias sanitarias sobre una
temprana segunda ola la región apuesta
por volver a la normalidad